good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2742
containment class euclid disruption
class
kennick and risk class critical
special containment procedures scp-2742
instances should be contained in an
aquatic containment chamber
outfitted with a count counter to
monitor hume levels
one long ranged reality adjuster should
be kept focused
on the chamber at all times increasing
the hume level of the chamber
to keep the scp-2742 instances
fed hume levels should be around the
area average
as the result of the changes from
feeding the lrra
should be checked for maintenance on a
weekly basis to ensure
optimal hume levels are kept if any
changes in hume levels are detected
level 4 2742 personnel should be
notified
immediately any new scp-2742 instances
should either be transferred to
containment sites or used in experiments
at secure testing facilities
in the event of a containment breach or
discovery of instances
an lra should be focused on any aquatic
location
away from civilians and increase the
location's hume level
once the instances arrive at the
location a task force will be deployed
for containment if a 2742
vardia event occurs the area of the
event should be quarantined for as long
as necessary
following the end of the event the area
should be assessed for any remaining
anomalies
and personnel should be interviewed any
remains of an scp-2742-1 instance
should be collected and studied
description scp-274 is a species of
anomalous aquatic animals
resembling angular formes in body shape
scp-2742
instances have 1.5 meter long
trilaterally symmetric bodies
with slight edges separating each side
the instances are dark purple in
coloration with lighter patches on
certain parts
the head is a tetrahedron composed of a
grey rocky material
extending from each edge on the base are
frills resembling the gills of ambostoma
mexicanum
likely used in feeding or as a sensory
organ
each side of the body has a row of three
bioluminescent sacs
which rapidly flash random colors
scp-2742 instances do not have blood or
any similar substance
instances reproduce asexually
transforming a sac on their body
into a new instance a single instance
may reproduce up to nine
times as the sacks do not regenerate
the entities are calivores consuming the
strength of reality for sustenance
this is seen as a decrease in hume
levels within a 15 meter spherical
region
around the head of an instance as more
instances enter a single region the
decrease will become more severe
once seven are present any additional
instances will begin to die from
starvation
as a result scp-2742 are rarely seen in
groups
though they can form schools instances
also move between locations frequently
suggesting that staying in one area can
also lead to starvation
effects of the hume decrease include a
region of visual distortions in the area
normally resembling those caused by heat
waves
sounds also undergo various distortions
a sense of unease is often reported from
subjects sometimes escalating to terror
there is also a higher chance of
non-anomalous subjects becoming reality
benders
for the duration of the decrease in most
subjects this is done unintentionally
often stemming from changes in
perception being applied to the area
it is also more likely for anomalous
phenomenon to spontaneously occur
though it is rare for anything created
during this to exist
outside of the area when an scp-2742
instance dies
either from starvation or other means
the bioluminescent sacks will burst
and stop glowing there is a chance that
a 2742 varnia event will occur
which entails a temporary restructuring
of reality in a spherical region
the event has an approximate radius of
30 meters an
outside view of the event shows the area
as repeatedly bending and twisting
though no such phenomena are described
by those entering or
inside it what happens in an event
varies though hallucinations and
appearances of anomalous entities
are common after an event the area will
return to normal
though some objects created or distorted
in it
remain hume levels will increase to the
local average after approximately 5
hours
no casualties have occurred from these
events the remains of the scp-2742
instance are typically heavily damaged
on recovery
the remains do not appear to decay
not all entity deaths result in a 2742
vardia event with four out of nine
recorded deaths not causing one
whether the probability of an event
occurring is determined by outside
factors or by chance
is unknown discovery log
scp-2742-1 was detected in lake ontario
after a trail of lower than usual hume
levels were detected by
kenji kent ranged monitors on foundation
patrol boats
mobile task force and u3 limnophobia
were dispatched to track and contain the
cause of this decrease
on the 15th of october 2016. scp-2742-1
was discovered on a yacht
stored in an aquarium at the back of the
ship interrogation of the ship's crew
revealed that they were members of group
of interest
03088 also known as the church of the
second high toth
and were planning on bringing the
anomaly referred to as
nol ave back to a church facility for
preservation
a ritual was used by the crew to let
them detect
changes in reality leading to the
discovery of scp-2742
one due to the effects of the reality
decrease
a full interview was unable to be
performed at the time of discovery
the crew was detained interrogated and
subsequently administered amnestics
scp-2742-1 was brought to site 201
for containment and the yacht was stored
for investigation
since the containment of scp-2742-1
24 instances have been born nine of
which have died
scp-2742
is the only other instance to have been
discovered in the wild
also found in lake ontario the instance
died
during recovery addendum 1
2742 vardia event log
note due to difficulties in retrieving
footage of these events
most of the known details are based on
reports from personnel
conflicting reports will be described
event 1 19th of october 2016
location site 201 instance
scp-2742-8 cause of instance death
starvation description
a purple silhouette of an elongated
scp-2742
instance designated scp-2742
e1 begins moving through the area
carving holes in walls and
personnel it would pass through the
walls become gray in color
as an object described as a three sphere
manifests
the silhouette passes into the three
sphere causing a ripple effect on its
surface
the object remains until the end of the
event other personnel reports seeing
hallways flooded with a liquid appearing
as visual static
which had no mass to it recovered items
a standard issue foundation water bottle
containing a gray liquid
composed primarily of carbon
event number two date 2nd of november
2016 location site 201
instance scp-2742
9 cause of instance death starvation
description the entire area becomes
black
with personnel experiencing the effects
of zero gravity
a large white entity is seen in the
distance rapidly changing in size and
shape
occasionally being separated in half and
reforming
various white dots and amorphous shapes
are seen coming off of it
scp-2742e1 appears in the distance
at this point some personnel report
being pulled towards the entity
which reportedly had a hume level of
zero around it
descriptions following this vary
other personnel reported the white
entity breaking apart
into clusters of stars and some nebulae
some personnel would morph and divide
into miniature solar systems of varying
structure
which would disintegrate or change shape
when near scp-2742
e1 a dark blue silhouette manifests in
the distance
with a vaguely humanoid torso a
spherical head on the chest
legs that have a mass of tendrils as the
lower half and
five amorphous objects that circle
around the torso
designated scp-2742 e2
the silhouette is positioned above
assorted gas clouds researchers had
burst into
which had formed into a large disk
recovered items 11 spheres composed of
assorted human tissues
varying in size with genetic matches to
personnel
in the event a foundation issued tablet
with the words
the lesser of mind envies inscribed on
the screen
with a corner of the device stretched
out one meter in length
additional notes contrary to reports
no changes in hume levels were detected
during this
testimony dr alana varda
i spent a good while tumbling around
that boring void
sure the cosmic paint splatter was
interesting but there was a whole lack
of excitement
up until the serpent thing began
slithering its way towards me
i tried to push myself away but that's
difficult to do when you can't push on
anything
i saw james and the rest of them get
sucked towards it and disfigured so i
freaked out and got a nice lung full of
bitter nothing
next thing i knew i was joining them i
got stretched and split and reformed
repeatedly
while the colors engulfing me beat
disharmonious drums
my eyes turned into fractals and my
spine elongated to
somewhere while that thing nolos
its nine eyes just stared thank whatever
god exists that i'm not in its vision
now
event number three date 10th of november
2016. location testing facility 31
instance 2742-13
cause of instance death starvation
description
the area's floor bends into an orange
platform with a large metal statue in
the center of it
the platform is constructed from bones
of unknown entities
some of which protrude from its surface
the statue depicts a tripedal entity
with tendrils wrapping around its torso
a crescent-shaped head and two
femur-shaped protrusions extending from
its back
the walls expand until the platform
appears to be in space
surrounded by yellow nebulae and dark
planets
a bright pink sphere with circular
patterns moving across it illuminates
the area
various silhouettes of different
entities appear on the platform and
begin to worship the statue
personnel either turned into the
silhouettes or joined in the worshipping
common noises in the area included
chirping gargling and chanting
on occasion the entities were
accidentally forced off of the platform
and dissolved into clouds of particles
one researcher
stated that they saw the entity scp-2742
e2 floating overhead
recovered items the statue which bears
an inscription in ortothan that says
all praise your lord of all mind a
liquid composed of water
carbon and sulfur testimony
dr selman halluck it was beautiful
what you want me to say more did the
others sound too delusional with their
descriptions
it would be impressive if they didn't
being there bowing and shouting and
i we had no privacy there but nothing
cared
we could melt into each other and dance
through mental rivers as
wafts of the burning skeptical thoughts
filled the glory of the whole
it wasn't a big deal that nobody could
dissent since we had no reason to
event number four date 24th of november
2016
location testing facility 31
instance scp 2742
17 cause of instance death physical
trauma
description the event began in a similar
manner to event three
though one researcher transformed into
the shape of the statue at the start
eventually personnel reported
scp-2742-e-2
appearing in front of them the crowd
around the statue starts to panic
and the entity reportedly vanished at
this point
personnel report losing all control over
their bodies
stating that scp-2742-e-2
had forced them out of their minds the
researcher who became the statue
transforms into a white silhouette of
the entity it depicts
designated as scp-2742 e3
versions of scp-2742 e2
emerge from crowd members and fly
towards a cp-2742
e3 with the researcher reportedly
blacking out
the scp-2742 e2 versions vanish
and scp-2742e3 can be seen spasming
while releasing blue light the platform
breaks apart
as the pink sphere contorts recovered
items
none note this event was experienced by
a crew of three agents from mobile task
force and u3
who were on a foundation containment
submersible during this
the names of the agents are used in this
due to there being few personnel
involved
event number five date first of december
2016 location underwater
lake ontario instance scp-2742-22
cause of instance death prior injuries
description the area turns black with a
cluster of light specs in the distance
the corpse of scp-2742-22 transforms
into scp-2742 e1
and begins to swim around the
submersible transforms into scp-2742-a3
and agent garvon neil becomes scp-2742e2
the interior of the vehicle turns to
resemble white metallic versions of body
tissues
and organs agents alan bridger and canna
canarodina
begin yelling various words of an
unidentified language
repeatedly as agent neil phases out of
scp-2742
e3 moving towards scp-2742
e-1 he enters the head of the silhouette
and after several minutes
scp-2742e1 transforms
into a large four-dimensional maze which
agent neal is inside of
neil attempts to attack the maze with
the objects circling him
which have transformed into long
triangles parts of the maze break and it
begins to rapidly spin around
causing neil to be thrown around inside
of it
at this point agents bridger and rodina
pass out from exhaustion
based on damaged footage from a camera
on the submersible
agent neal continues to be thrown around
until the maze breaks apart
scp-2742-e-1 reforms
and splits apart into various smaller
versions
of itself recovered items
11 slivers of tissues suspected to be
from scp-2742-22
found in the submersibles ballast a red
spike with
various unidentified thumaturgical
symbols carved on it
additional notes all agents were
recovered when the submersible
resurfaced an hour
after the supposed end of the event
agent neil is currently undergoing
medical and psychological treatment
after being found unresponsive and
unaware of recovery agents
while repeatedly tapping his fingers the
corpse of scp-2742
is presumed to have been eviscerated
during the event
as psychological issues are now known to
result from 2742 varda events
all upcoming experiments involving
scp-2742
at testing facility 31 have been
cancelled
instances stored at the facility are
being transported to nearby sites
testimony agent alan bridger
rodina and i couldn't talk to each other
but we knew we were going through the
same hell
we weren't just compelled to chant about
whatever it was
we were being forced to something was
actively pushing and prying at my
thoughts
scraping something that made us speak
even when i thumped onto the floor
i kept feeling it hold on to and reach
through my brain in every place it
shouldn't
last i remember it just frantically
carving for a while before it stopped
addendum 2 level 4 access required
event number 6 date 18th of january 2017
location area 12 instance
unknown cause of instance death none
description the area becomes black and
all walls melt into the floor with a
white three sphere manifesting after
various red cracks appear along this
three sphere
and it bursts after a minute ejecting a
grace silhouette of an scp-2742
instance out of it the silhouette floats
through the area
until a second three sphere forms which
it enters
after entrance the three sphere vanishes
and the event ends
recovered items a four meter tall mass
composed of skin tissues from scp-2742
instances
resembling scp-2742 e1 in shape
with tendrils anchoring to the ground
one liter of scp-874 in the instance
containment chamber
additional notes during this event all
scranton reality anchors at area 12
shut off accompanied by a large increase
in humes
multiple hallways leading to the
scp-2742 containment chamber
had also collapsed injuring five
researchers
security footage of the containment
chamber immediately prior to the event
show no signs of any instance deaths
suggesting that a 2742
vardia event can occur at any time
containment procedures are being
reassessed by the secure containment
board
to ensure proper containment of scp-2742
instances information regarding this
event has been restricted
to prevent fears of major reality shifts
from low-level personnel
whether the shutdown of sras was caused
by the anomaly
or an outside force is under
investigation
group of interest number zero three zero
eighty eight
document thirty seven the following is a
document recovered by agent marth
corinne
from an artothen church in yena germany
due to similarities between the
narrative of this story
and certain 2742 barnea events
it has been included in this document
all text has been translated from
ortothan
to english notice to readers
this story involves events that occurred
during the first haith
it is likely that certain details in the
story have been modified since it was
first
told due to the age of the story and the
events it concerns
readers should not consider this
information to be completely accurate
any questions regarding this along with
any additional information on the story
should be brought to any church scholar
may the holy fourth forever protect us
eiv scholar diana olivier branch of
history
of all the bodiless it was the fourth
aeon of the high top
the lesser deities combated and
slaughtered for measly chunks of
territory in the recesses of the
universe
as the almighty viz gods ruled across
the galactic plains
after the despair that was the first
turmoil
all was at rest eurovol
the deity of osrock mind gazed up at the
sparkling plains with fear
and animosity the viz gods should not
have so much power
nor should they have such massive
kingdoms nor should they exist
he knew that it was an impossibility to
level them and their realms even with
great effort
the chasms of eurovol's mind twisted and
bent as a plan was formulated to erase
it all
as blood marred the constellations and
the last galactic arm dispersed
the idea was completed
he left the shattered galaxy of you and
flew towards the empire of the thought
conglomerate
ruled by vi mind urjo great swaths of
yellow nebulae
galaxies and grey harvested stars
circulated on the outskirts of the
unimaginable
psychic core the swarming bodiless
telepaths released a pink glow
as they labored for the vi-mind's will
the trillion followers bowed and praised
their lord
their free will lost centuries ago
dedicating their existences to the
worship of her
they danced upon stellar warnings
constructed from the remains of those
that lived before
the insubordinate ones eurovol
knew of the potential of their minds and
used his power to exploit it
one by one the followers minds were
replaced
and they all became eurovol erjo sensed
a loss in faith
and dispatched a body of hers to resolve
the issue
the euro of all trillion mentally
bombarded erjo
and gradually her conscious was melted
and absorbed
his physical form wretched and
disjointed from the strain
but it mattered not the bodies of urival
soared out of the collapsed empire and
into the eaton chaos
the void carved out by the ancient nolos
the beast swam through the inky madness
shaping the flowing realm with its
imagination
strange colors and shapes whispered and
vanished as he passed through the
unnatural
things that were between life and death
reached out for an end
and were peeled away to other dredges
if the first could be taken the rest of
the viz gods would go to
the strength of the psychics coursed
through eurovol
as his advent came delegating the
perception of surroundings to entities
outside of the realm
the area would not overload his focus
the proxies assembled into a grid around
the first
and he began to channel his mind into it
wave after wave of mental slices tore
through the psychic barriers surrounding
its brain
yet the beast only waited after a
seemingly
timeless century past a gap had been
carved into the barrier
and eurovol lunged into the depth that
awaited him
what was learned and witnessed within
the thing will remain
unknown on the day of the entrance a
scream rang out through the denizens of
the universe and all of its
dimensions the secrets that were
uncovered
trapped and buffeted eurovol the alien
unknowns encompassing him
it could not be incorporated into
himself or controlled
though it had begun to do so to him he
fought for sanity but it was futile
as he lashed out in fright nolos
convulsed and tore itself into many
children
ejecting them as far as the nameless
creator can perceive
eurovol lost the grip on his bodies
and the trillions of them collapsed
transformed into unconscious
husks the persuasive warmth of the
psychic core faded and the empire
released its last echoes
the consumed realms were a colorful
chaos no more
with vast lands relinquished from their
prior owners
the second turmoil began and peace
became
a forgotten concept eurovol lost the
ability to permanently connect
to any corporeal form in his madness
forced into the role of a psychic nomad
the mind continues to roam across haith
drifting from being to being in search
of a body to claim as his
if one feels an unknown presence carve
at you
briefly tugging on the strings and
filaments of your mind
as alien ideas spill forth your of all
the bodyless
has gone through you
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran professor puffer
the morrigan retalias
karim el ashmuy jebby
pure osmium sayo diodemnatus
revenant brian sanchez
matthew gilmore eric corbidge
kawaii fire keeper longinus
carcasteth aqua king madding
james saba and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you